opposites honest interviews now you
might know him as Ryan right you know
the crazy guy constant weed smoker
insane masturbator psycho selling out of
control man
what today we're going to get to know
not Ryan Wright no no no we're gonna get
to know Greg oppa it starts here with
another acha son honest interview I
can't wait to see what he's all about
I bet it clear mine real fun stuff grey
album ladies and gentlemen
great what's up [ __ ] yeah it's on to
some baby
that's right I'm sorry yeah yeah come in
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah how you doing
okay what huh what's up uh yeah okay
yeah okay man all right give you your
video blog yeah yeah yeah that's what we
do need a chill offer sir
okay relax it's been a long four months
left
yeah what happens have changed so this
is where the famous a real real rejects
we we're gonna do some stuff here
yeah oh don't go there okay you do use
the restroom before coming here
uh no I wanted to make a deposit later
well you can't I'm serious what's your
name again it's aqua fun awesome
yeah don't go red okay well you know
we've been talking for it's two years
but there's a lot of money kept can I
sit down yeah okay
um nah uh maybe a little later yeah I
just wanted to are you about to we
wanted to get to know the real grit
great ALPA surprisingly a lot like Ryan
right that's don't ever make sure Ryan
Ryan you're gay okay okay okay okay
don't ever make me get okay damn what
what the [ __ ]
okay did you uh hear that did you
I hear anything swear to God I heard
something I did one second
it's all done
oh right
still here yeah
I'm gonna go smoke a cigarette don't
don't go in there
you never went in there not okay yeah
but that's it
you know how the black guys always get
blamed for that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] white guy tied up mom hello hello
hello hello hey Eddie
Hey oh [ __ ] this is gonna be so viral
okay uh all right I remember okay okay
oh hello John hey what's up you get oh
[ __ ] no no way didn't like move Haley
million oh don't worry don't worry he's
gonna go buy a home no I need to see
drivers the you know then the best thing
a black man can hear my side for
something white guys oh it's gonna be
all the whole Ukraine coming back don't
worry she's gonna toss it Wow you ties
your office is honest interview oh my
god
I got you on tape buddy film at 11:00
Hasan do you realize what you've done do
you realize what you've done buddy I
acha son have saved this guy John huh
yeah right Hakkasan yeah I'm fine Greg
why nothing I guess I'll see you in the
living room okay Greg
see you soon
clear mind little phone store channel
now I mock us on